PETER KING FOOTBALL MORNING
IN AMERICA. ONE OF THE GREAT
FOOTBALL WRITERS OF OUR
GENERATION PETER ALWAYS A
PLEASURE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US DAN. THANK
YOU. HOW ARE YOU? I'M DOING
GREAT. I'M DOING GREAT AS I
WAS DOING A LITTLE RESEARCH
FOR THE SHOW, YOU KNOW WEST
COAST TIME LAST NIGHT. I WAS
SAYING MAN. I HOPE I HOPE
PETER GETS HIS COLUMN A
LITTLE EARLY SO I CAN READ IT
BEFORE I GO TO BED AND YOU
DID.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. YOU'RE
WELCOME. AND I DID IT FOR YOU.
I KNOW YOU DID. I KNOW YOU
DID SO MANY SO MANY ANXIOUSLY
AWAITING THAT COLUMN EACH AND
EVERY MONDAY OBVIOUSLY FREE
AGENCY A BIG TOPIC IN THAT
ONE THAT THE PATRIOTS
BY FAR THE MOST AGGRESSIVE
TEAM OUT THERE YOU HAD A LINE
IN YOUR IN YOUR COLUMN THAT
THEY HAD A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION IN
GUARANTEES IN TWO DAYS, WHICH
IS ALMOST THE SAME AMOUNT
THAT ROBERT KRAFT PAID FOR
IS THAT RIGHT? YEAH, AND
YOU KNOW, I THINK THE OTHER
PART OF THAT WHOLE THING IS
JUST THE SIMPLE FACT THAT YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY BILL
BELICHICK NEVER DONE THIS
BEFORE ROBERT KRAFT HAS NEVER
DONE THIS BEFORE AND LOOK NO
MATTER WHAT WAY YOU YOU SPIN
IT, YOU KNOW HALF OF THEIR
TEAM WILL BE DIFFERENT HALF OF
THEIR STARTING TEAM IS GOING
WHAT IT WAS FOUR MONTHS AGO
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT
INCLUDES BIG STARS LIKE JOHN
IS SMITH WHO I THINK IN THAT
OFFENSE IS GOING TO BE A BIG
STAR TREE IN IT AND IT ALSO
INCLUDES RETURNING STARS LIKE
KYLE VAN NOY WHO I STILL
CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHY MIAMI
PAID HIM 15 MILLION DOLLARS
FOR 14 GAMES AND THEN LET
THEM GO. I STILL THINK HE'S A
HE'S A FORCE TO BE RECKONED.
IS AND YOU KNOW
, LOOK THE PATRIOTS ARE GOING
TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THE QUESTION
IS ALL GOING TO COME DOWN TO
CAM NEWTON AND WHAT HE HAS
LEFT, YOU KNOW, HE SURE
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS LIMITED
FOR A LOT OF LAST SEASON. HE
WAS NOT THROWING THE BALL.
WELL, WE'LL SEE IF THAT WAS
COVID RELATED OR WHATEVER,
BUT YOU KNOW TO ME I THINK
YOU KNOW, THE ONE MISSING
PIECE NOW ARE THE ONE PIECE
THAT WE REALLY DON'T KNOW
VERY MUCH ABOUT IS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AT
QUARTERBACK. SO THAT'S GOING
TO BE THE LITTLE MYSTERY
P WE WILL FALL. YEAH, THEY
BRING CAM BACK ON A
RELATIVELY TEAM FRIENDLY DEAL,
ESPECIALLY THIS ERA WHEN
STARTING QUARTERBACKS OR YOU
KNOW, MAKING THIRTY PLUS
MILLION AT LEAST THE YOU KNOW,
THE TOP 10 GUYS
HALF OF THEIR 22 STARTERS.
ARE GOING TO BE NEW OR GUYS
WHO HAVE LEFT AND THEN COME
BACK LIKE VANNOY. WHO DO YOU
THINK'S GOING TO HAVE THE
THE JOHNNY SMITH'S THE HUNTER
HENRY'S THE YOU KNOW, THE
AGRA LURES THE KENDRICK BORNS.
WELL, I THINK I THINK I
WOULD COMBINE THAT AND JUST
SAY THAT TO ME THE
BEST THE OFFENSE THAT BILL
BELICHICK REALLY LOVES
PLAYING JOSH MCDANIELS THE
OFFENSIVE COORDINATOR THE
OFFENSE THEY LOVE PLAYING IS
VERY TIGHT AND FRIENDLY AND
LOOK THE YEAR. IT WAS 10
YEARS AGO NOW, BUT THE YEAR
THEY HAD A GREAT OFFENSIVE
SEASON CENTERED AROUND AARON
HERNANDEZ AND ROB GRONKOWSKI
NOW ALMOST 10 YEARS AGO WHEN?
BASICALLY THOSE GUYS
COMBINED TO SCORE 24
TOUCHDOWNS, RIGHT? AND AND
AND IT WAS THAT IS WHAT I
THINK THEY WOULD REALLY LOVE
TO GET BACK TO BECAUSE YOU'RE
MOVING THE CHAIN SAFELY AND
YOU'RE DOING IT ON
GUYS, SO THAT IS WHAT I THINK
WE CAN REALLY EXPECT TO
HAPPEN. AND AND REALLY I
THINK ONE OF THE INTERESTING
PARTS ABOUT THEIR OFFENSE IS
THEY BASICALLY HAVE NOT HAD A
TIGHT END OF ANY SKILL OR
SUBSTANCE FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS. AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT IT THAT WAY AND YOU SAY
THIS IS WHAT WE LIKE TO DO
BEST, YOU KNOW PLAY TWO TIGHT
ENDS IN THE GAME AT THE SAME
ANY OR THEY AT LEAST HAVEN'T
HAD ANY I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE REVOLUTIONARILY DIFFERENT
FOR THE PATRIOTS AND IT'S
GOING TO ALLOW THEM EVEN IF
CAM NEWTON'S DOWNFIELD ARM IS
NOT WHAT IT WAS. I THINK IT'S
GOING TO ALLOW THEM TO BE
ABLE TO CONSIDER CONSISTENTLY
MOVE THE CHAINS. YEAH. I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT POINT,
YOU KNOW, HISTORICALLY TEAMS
THAT SPEND AS BIG AS THE
PATRIOTS SPENT IN FREE AGENCY.
IT DOESN'T REALLY GO WELL,
BUT I FEEL LIKE
CAUSE THE PATRIOTS THIS IS
THE PATRIOTS. IT JUST IT JUST
FEELS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
TO ME AND I LOVE I LOVE BOTH
OF THOSE TIGHT ENDS VERY
FAMILIAR WITH JOHNNY SMITH
FROM HIS YOU KNOW DAYS KIND
OF BACKING UP DELANIE WALKER
AND IN TENNESSEE, AND THEN
REALLY CAME INTO HIS OWN LAST
YEAR AND WHAT WHEN HEALTHY
THAT'S THAT'S A GUY THAT IS
OF THE BELICHICK MOLD PETER
BECAUSE HE'S A GOOD BLOCK OR
AS WELL SIMILAR TO GRONK IN
THAT. YEAH. YEAH, AND THE
OTHER THING THAT THE OTHER
THING REMEMBER ABOUT
WHO SMITH ARTHUR
UH SMITH THE OFFENSIVE
COORDINATOR IN TENNESSEE DID
EXACTLY WITH JAANU SMITH'S
WHAT JOSH MCDANIELS DID A
DECADE AGO IN THE PLAYOFF
GAME AGAINST THE TIM TEBOW
BRONCOS. HE PUT AARON
HERNANDEZ IN THE BACKFIELD,
RIGHT AND IN A PLAYOFF GAME
HERNANDEZ RAN FOR 70 OR 80
YARDS AND JOHN WHO SMITH HAS
DONE THAT AND HE'S DONE IT.
WELL, SO, YOU KNOW, WE'LL SEE.
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE
A FEW SURPRISES IN THAT NEW
ENGLAND OFFENSE.
SPEAKING OF SURPRISES WHO
SURPRISED YOU MAYBE FOR THE
MOVES THAT THEY DIDN'T MAKE
OR THE DIDN'T SPEND AS MUCH
MONEY AS YOU ANTICIPATED.
I CREDIT TEAMS FOR NOT
SPENDING MONEY BY THE WAY DAY,
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR
PEOPLE GET SO EXCITED ON
MARCH 20TH, MARCH 22ND,
WHATEVER AND THEN THEY ARE
ALMOST ALWAYS DISAPPOINTED
WITH WHAT HAPPENS AND WHAT
ENDS UP HAPPENING WITH THE
YOU KNOW WITH THE MONEY THAT
THEY DIDN'T SPEND. I MEAN,
GIVE YOU I'LL GIVE YOU A
TEAM THAT THAT I THINK SHOULD
BE GETTING SIGNIFICANT CREDIT.
THAT'S THE INDIANAPOLIS
COLTS BECAUSE
STILL NEED A REALLY GOOD
DOWNFIELD RECEIVING WEAPON.
YOU DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
GOING TO GET T Y HILTON BACK
YOU GOT SOME UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT WHETHER MICHAEL PITTMAN
IS GOING TO BE THAT GUY I
THINK.
THEY HOPE IS BUT THEY'RE NOT
REALLY SURE THAT HE'S GOING
TO BE.
68 IN THAT OFFENSE. BUT WHAT
I GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR IS THAT
THEY'VE GOT THREE GUYS WHO
THEY NEED TO PAY BIG MONEY
TO IN THE NEXT YEAR PLUS.
EVEN BEFORE A YEAR, YOU KNOW,
QUENTIN NELSON AND BRADEN
SMITH THE UNDERRATED RIGHT
TACKLE. THEY HAVE EVERYBODY
KNOWS NELSON. AND THEN ALSO
DAIRY IS LEONARD ON DEFENSE.
SO, YOU KNOW THAT RIGHT THERE
IS
I'M GOING TO GUESS ABOUT 50
MILLION DOLLARS AVERAGE ON THE
CAMP LONG TERM, YOU KNOW FOR
THE NEXT DAY THREE YEARS AND
AND SO YOU DON'T WANT TO JUST
SAY HEY, WE GOT A LOT OF CAP
ROOM. LET'S GO SPEND IT. WELL
IF YOU SPEND A LOT THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO BE
STRUGGLING TO SIGN THE
HOMEGROWN TALENT THAT YOU
LOVE. SO I LOOK AT
INDIANAPOLIS IN THIS IN THE
EARLY DAYS OF FREE AGENCY AND
SAY
I THINK THEIR PATIENTS HAS
BEEN QUITE SMART NOW, I WOULD
AGREE WITH THAT ABOUT ABOUT
THE COLTS. LET ME ASK YOU
ABOUT DESHAUN WATSON THREE
MORE WOMEN TODAY FILED
LAWSUITS THERE NOW TEN CIVIL
SUITS FILED AGAINST THE
TEXANS QUARTERBACK FROM WOMEN
WHO WORK WITH HIM AS A
MASSAGE THERAPIST CLAIMING
THAT WATSON SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED THEM DURING THE
MASSAGES JUST FROM A FROM A
LEGAL STANDPOINT FROM THE NFL
SIDE THERE.
AN INVESTIGATION UNDERWAY.
HOW DOES THIS PLAY OUT FROM A
I THINK IT'S TOO EARLY TO
TELL DAN BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
, YOU KNOW, THE NFL HAS NOT
SHOWN THE THE SAME
WILLINGNESS WHEN THERE ARE
CIVIL SUITS, YOU
KNOW, FILED VERSUS CRIMINAL
SUITS AND YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY
A CRIMINAL CASE COULD RESULT
IN A CONVICTION OR MULTIPLE
CONVICTIONS. BUT AS OF RIGHT
NOW, THESE ARE CIVIL SUITS WE
REMEMBER SIX YEARS AGO SEVEN
YEARS AGO. NOW WHEN WHEN RAY
RICE HAD HIS INCIDENT
WITH HIS FIANCEE NOW WIFE IN
AN ELEVATOR IN ATLANTIC CITY,
ADRIAN PETERSON HAD HIS
SITUATION WITH HIS SON AS
CORPORAL PUNISHMENT SITUATION
AND SO BOTH OF THOSE CASES
WHEN THEY WENT TO COURT WERE,
YOU KNOW, THEY WERE THEY
WERE INVESTIGATED HIS
CASES AND IN THOSE CAKE IN
THE NFL THEN CAN TAKE THE
PLAYER OFF THE FIELD UNTIL
THOSE CASES HAVE BEEN DECIDED
WHICH IS WHAT THEY DID IN
THOSE CASES. AND SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WHAT I THINK
UNTIL WE FIND OUT
IF THIS BECOMES A CRIMINAL
CASE AND IT IS IN COURT.
YOU KNOW AS WE APPROACH THE
SEASON, I THINK THERE'S A
CHANCE THE NFL WOULD PUT
WATSON ON THE COMMISSIONERS.
THE LIST AND BASICALLY MAKE
IT HE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
PLAY NO MATTER WHETHER
HOUSTON OR ANY OTHER TEAM
WOULD WOULD WANT HIM TO PLAY.
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE THING
TO LOOK OUT FOR BUT BUT I
ALSO THINK WE BASICALLY GOT
ALMOST SIX MONTHS NOW BEFORE
, YOU KNOW, THE GAMES ARE
PLAYED AND SO I THINK A LOT
CAN HAPPEN BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN BUT TO ME, I THINK THAT
IS THE BIGGEST FACTOR IS THIS
ACE OR WILL IT JUST A CIVIL
CASE THE THE UPSHOT THOUGH
RIGHT NOW, IS THAT IF THE
TEXANS WERE EVER THINKING OF
EVEN POSSIBLY TRADING HIM?
WELL, THEY CAN'T DO IT NOW.
NOBODY'S GOING TO WANT TO
TAKE IT GUY WITH
THIS HANGING OVER HIS HEAD.
SO I THINK THE DESHAUN WATSON,
YOU KNOW FUTURE IS A
FOOTBALL PLAYER AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW, HIS FUTURE IN, YOU
WITH THE LEGAL AUTHORITIES
RIGHT NOW IS IS JUST VERY
MUCH IN DOUBT. WOULD YOU YOU
HAD THIS IN YOUR COLUMN
THOUGH WHEN TALKING TO ONE
GENERAL MANAGER ARE YOU'RE
OBVIOUSLY MONITORING
MONITORING THIS SITUATION IF
YOU WERE PREVIOUSLY
INTERESTED IN DESHAUN WATSON
AS A QUARTERBACK FOR YOUR
I MEAN, WOULD YOU POTENTIALLY
SWOOP IN THERE AND TRY TO GET
HIM AT A DISCOUNTED RATE
BECAUSE OF WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW? THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. I THINK THERE ARE
SOME GENERAL MANAGERS WHO
WOULD DO THAT. THERE'S SOME
OWNERS WHO IF THEY THOUGHT IN
MY OPINION THEY COULD I
DON'T WANT TO SAY GET AWAY
WITH IT. BUT IF THEY COULD
TAKE THE PUBLIC SCORN, YOU
KNOW ON THIS THAT THEY MIGHT
TRY TO DO IT BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK
I'VE NOT SPOKEN TO ANYBODY
WHO THINKS THAT THIS MEANS
THAT DESHAUN WATSON. HE'S
NEVER GOING TO PLAY FOOTBALL
AGAIN. HE OBVIOUSLY IT'S WELL,
I SHOULDN'T SAY OBVIOUSLY,
BUT HE VERY MOST LIKELY WILL
BUT I JUST DON'T SEE HOW
YOU COULD STAND UP IN FRONT
OF YOUR FAN BASE RIGHT NOW.
ANNOUNCED THAT YOU WERE
TRADING FOR SOMEONE WHOS GOT
12 WOMEN ACCUSING HIM.
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
JUST YOU KNOW, IF IF I WERE A
SEASON TICKET HOLDER THAT
TEAM THAT WOULD BE REALLY
REALLY HARD FOR ME TO SWALLOW
NO MATTER HOW MUCH I WANTED
TO SEAN WATSON THE FOOTBALL
PLAYER. SO I WOULDN'T EXPECT
THAT ANY TEAM IS GOING TO
TRADE FOR HIM RIGHT NOW.
YEAH, THAT'S THAT'S CERTAINLY
GOING TO BE A FASCINATING
SITUATION TO WATCH FROM A
FROM A FOOTBALL STANDPOINT IN
A LEGAL STANDPOINT REGARDING
A DESHAUN WATSON AND THE
TEXANS WHAT'S GOING DOWN
RIGHT NOW ON A LIGHTER NOTE
PETER. WE GOT TO WRAP IT UP
SOON. BUT OUR NEXT GUEST IS
JEFF BOWLS FROM YOUR OHIO
BOBCATS. WOW PUMPS ARE YOU?
YEAH. I'M EXCITED GOOD FOR
JEFF AND GOOD FOR THAT TEAM.
I TALKED TO HIM THE OTHER
NIGHT WHEN HE WAS ON HIS WAY
HOME FROM BLOOM ON HIS WAY
BACK FROM BLOOMINGTON TO
INDIANAPOLIS.
I DIDN'T TALK TO HIM. PARDON
ME. I TEXTED WITH HIM AND
SOME OF THAT MY COLUMN TODAY,
BUT WHAT IS SO INTERESTING
AND WHAT I REALLY REALLY
ADMIRE ABOUT THIS OHIO TEAM,
THAT IT WAS
4745 WITH JUST UNDER THREE
MINUTES LEFT IN THE GAME.
THEY WERE LEADING VIRGINIA
THE NATIONAL CHAMP DEFENDING
CHAMPS AND NOW IS WHEN IT'S
REALLY THE TOUGH TIME OF THE
GAME AND YOU WOULD THINK
THAT THE PREMIER TEAMS THE
TEAMS THAT HAVE BEEN IN THIS
SPACE BEFORE WOULD TAKE OVER
AND AT THAT POINT, OHIO NONE
WHOM NONE OF THEIR PLAYERS
THAT EVER PLAYED IN A GAME
NEARLY AS BIG AS THIS BEFORE
NEVER IN AN NCAA TOURNAMENT
BEFORE AND THEY CAME OUT AND
THEY MADE THEIR LAST 9 SHOTS
OF THE GAME 3 FROM THE FLOOR
AND AND SIX FROM THE FOUL
LINE AND THAT TELLS ME THAT
JEFF BOWLS AND THOSE GUYS
ARE DOING SOMETHING RIGHT.
THEY PREPARE THEIR GUY.
FOR BIG SITUATIONS AND THEY
REALLY CAME THROUGH IN ONE
SATURDAY NIGHT AT ASSEMBLY
HALL. SO THAT'LL BE FUN
TONIGHT TO WATCH THAT WILL
TAKE IT ON CREATING THE NIGHT
PETER. WE GOT TO ROLL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
YOU DO. I HONESTLY I MEANT
EVERYTHING I SAID, I'D LOVE
YOUR CALL AND I'VE BEEN
READING IT FOR AS LONG AS I
WELL, THANKS SO MUCH DAN MUCH
MUCH APPRECIATED. WE'LL TALK
TO YOU SOON. THE GREAT PETER